[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
citrouille et bonbons vont-ils fondre
pour Halloween à quelques jours de la
Toussaint les températures frôlent
encore les 30 degrés dans le Sud-Ouest
comme à Toulouse image et réactions à
chaud dès le début de ce journal avec
via Occitanie
il témoigne d'une époque et du transport
des marchandises du siècle passé le
bateau l'espérance 3 vogue de nouveau
sur le lac d'Annecy une reproduction
historique et pédagogique qui fait le
bonheur de ses passagers contemporains
et que nous fera découvrir la chaîne 8
pont-blanc dans un instant journaliste
écrivain drôle et intelligent Philippe
Bouvard reste à plus de 90 ans une des
personnalités préférées des Français
auteur d'un nouveau livre sur sa
carrière il m'a accordé un entretien
exclusif à découvrir bientôt sur TV5
Monde extrait en avant-première dans ce
journal et puis si vous deveniez
apprenti sorcier la magie Harry Potter
investit un château en Bretagne pour les
vacances de la Toussaint la rédaction de
TVA à Rennes nous emmènera dans les
couloirs de cette école des sorciers
bien réels
mais on ouvre donc ce journal avec
l'extrême douceur voir la chaleur qui
perdure sur une bonne partie du pays en
pleine vacances de la Toussaint et à
quelques jours du mois de novembre les
températures grimpent encore jusqu'à 30
degrés dans le Sud-Ouest un coup de
chaud automnale qui étonne bien sûr et
qui interpelle pour la saison ecoutez
ces quelques avis de toulousain au micro
dan Alger pour via Occitanie dans la
ville rose ou des records de température
viennent d'être battues les t-shirts
sont d'ailleurs de sortie
j'en profite bien sûr ça me fait plaisir
qu'il fasse beau et qui fasse chaud mais
en même temps
en même temps je sais que c'est pas
normal le top 100 c'est le début des
feuilles mortes des perds ont commencé à
sortir les vestes les bonnets les et là
on sera en plein été quoi honnêtement ça
me fait pas mal peur parce que enfin ça
nous montre en fait encore une fois que
le monde court droit vers la catastrophe
on sait qu'on profite du moment mais que
que c'est pas positif
voilà de l'inquiétude de vous l'entendez
dans ces réactions qui résonnent
évidemment avec les fortes chaleurs qu'a
connu la France cet été aujourd'hui
encore une majeure partie du territoire
est soumise à des restrictions du à la
sécheresse l'utilisation de l'eau
potable est évidemment interrogée dans
ce contexte en Gironde vous allez le
voir une entreprise qui copie c'est son
nom valorise l'eau de pluie grâce à 5
conceptions brevetées au niveau européen
des innovations à destination des
industriels des grandes surfaces ou
encore des bâtiments publics les
explications divan branchies pour la
rédaction de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest à Bordeaux
de pluie une ressource naturelle
inépuisable et gratuite que l'on
retrouve en moyenne 124 jours par an à
Bordeaux alors en 2005 Jacques Albert
Roussel crée la société quipopy avec une
idée toute simple récupérez cette eau et
l'utiliser les usages de l'eau de pluie
peuvent faire de nos besoins on récupère
entre eux surprenant et intéressant et
que des bâtiments qui font 500 000 m²,
on arrive à des rendements très
impressionnants chasse d'eau arrosage
des sols ou lavage de voiture autant de
gestes du quotidien en entreprise qui ne
nécessite pas forcément de l'eau potable
la conversion est alors possible grâce à
un système de filtration donc on va
installer un filtre qui lui va
emmagasiner toutes les eaux qu'on dit
météoriques toutes les eaux qui tombent
sur la toiture on va le faire on va
aller faire passer dans ce filtre pour
les collecter et les stocker dans le
volume de stockage et après quoi on va
les envoyer dans le local technique et
qui va permettre de faire la bascule
d'un réseau à l'autre entreprise de
bricolage chaîne de restaurant ou
supermarché au total plus de 2000
chantiers ont déjà été réalisés sur le
territoire national car à l'origine les
entreprises sont libres d'installer ou
non un récupérateur d'eau de pluie nous
faisons partie de l'Europe et que nous
avons pas les mêmes réglementations dans
ce qui concerne le cycle de l'eau
effectivement dans certains pays
d'Europe du Nord notamment
de la Finlande et la Suède le double
réseau dans un immeuble est obligatoire
sinon vous avez pas le permis de
construire un sujet mis sur la table à
l'Assemblée nationale la députée du
bassin d'Arcachon Sophie panonacle a
déposé une proposition de loi afin de
créer une obligation pour tout nouveau
bâtiment d'être équipé d'un récupérateur
d'eau de pluie
[Applaudissements]
de la toiture des bâtiments à la
rénovation d'un moulin dans ce journal
prononce à présent la direction de
l'aube ou le travail unique d'une
entreprise permet de redonner vie à de
vieilles structures dernier exploit en
date l'ensemble mécanique et la toiture
d'un moulin datant du XVIIe siècle près
de 2000 heures de travail ont été
nécessaires pour réaliser l'ouvrage qui
témoigne d'un savoir-faire exceptionnel
un reportage de Canal 32 sur place
ce matin des Aubois ont pu croiser sur
la route cette livraison exceptionnelle
une coiffe de Moulins en bois construite
et assemblée à courteronge ça fait 6
mètres 60 de d'envergure et ça fait 10
tonnes 5 de poids au bout il va y avoir
des ailes de 20 m d'envergure 2 x 10 on
peut mettre trois salariés ont travaillé
durant près de 2000 heures pour réaliser
cette commande d'un particulier résidant
en Seine-et-Marne
centrale historique il s'est appuyé sur
le savoir-faire de l'entreprise pour
reconstituer l'ouvrage tout est en
assemblage traditionnel attenons
mortaise et chevilles c'est réellement
une technique qui a été complètement
oubliée sur lequel on a dû à travers des
livres et des ouvrages du 18e du 19e
siècle retrouver en fait le les dessins
pour pouvoir comprendre comment il
fonctionnait il y a beaucoup de
mécaniques dans peu d'espace cette
expérience rare dans le domaine de la
restauration de Moulins s'appuie avant
tout sur la passion dans ce domaine
d'après ses charpentiers seuls 3 à 4
entreprises françaises répondent à ce
type de commande aujourd'hui on en a
fait une spécificité de l'entreprise
puisque on réalise maintenant
pratiquement chaque année entre 1 et 2
moulins pour cette pièce unique le
trajet de 140 km devrait s'effectuer en
6 heures au lieu d'une heure trente là
c'est vraiment de grosses difficultés je
pense les bois sont positionnées assez
bas au niveau de la route tout ce qui
est panneau qui certes sécurité ça va
vous poser quelques soucis cette coiffe
se compose de tuiles en châtaigniers
d'une charpente en chêne
des séries au boises en collaboré à la
fourniture des éléments cette coiffe
devrait être déposée et ornée la tour du
moulin ce mardi
un seul commerce vous manquez tout est
dépeuplé l'adage pas tout à fait exact
et malheureusement bien connu dans les
territoires les plus ruraux de notre
pays la fermeture d'une brasserie d'une
boulangerie ou encore d'une bouche riz
et souvent vécue comme un déchirement
par la population exemple près du Mans
avec ce sujet d'Enzo Maubert pour LM TV
Sarthe
c'est une fermeture dont le maire ce
serait bien passé depuis début octobre
ce commerce multiservices n'accueille
plus aucun client du jour au lendemain
le gérant a baissé le rideau pour des
raisons personnelles laissant un grand
vide dans le village on avait beaucoup
de rencontres qui se faisaient ici
particulièrement comme une journée comme
celle-là où il fait beau puisque on
avait les terrasses donc les gens
venaient aussi au niveau du pain
puisqu'il faisait aussi dépôt de pain et
puis on en profite pour prendre un café
et on discute et puis on échange sur
l'actualité du village quoi on veut être
une commune vivante on a des projets
donc il est primordial pour nous d'avoir
un commerce qui fonctionne restaurant
post presse épicerie depuis deux ans
l'ancien commerce proposé presque tous
les services nécessaires à la population
et au salon de coiffure d'à côté on
attend avec impatience un nouveau
repreneur c'est beaucoup moins vivant et
moins dynamique quoi on sent que la
place est devenue un peu plus déserte en
attendant habitant et élus s'organise
depuis la fermeture des bénévoles se
relaient tous les matins pour ouvrir ce
dépôt de pain devenu un lieu de
rencontre ça de rencontrer d'autres
personnes et de discuter c'est aussi un
endroit convivial la municipalité a déjà
reçu quatre candidatures de potentiels
repreneurs de quoi redonner espoir aux
habitants qui n'attendent qu'une chose
boire un petit noir sur la place du
village
pratique que numéro 1 en Inde et au
Pakistan quasi méconnu en Europe le
cricket est un sport complexe pour les
non initiés à Épinal dans l'Est de la
France une équipe vient d'être créée
grâce à la volonté de réfugier ils vont
désormais évoluer au sein du club de
baseball local un exemple d'inclusion
par le sport qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine nationale de l'intégration des
étrangers et primo arrivant Louise
hamunda et Thomas Hermann pour vos jet
télévision
des gestes maîtrisés dont nous ne
tenterons pas d'expliquer les règles peu
connues en France et on passe de
s'inscrire dans le paysage sportif
vosgien nous sommes à Épinal dans le
quartier du Plateau de la justice où une
équipe de cricket vient de se former les
joueurs entendent 17 et 27 ans leurs
points communs tous sont le statut de
réfugiés venu d'Asie du Sud souvent tout
seul certains ont tissaient des amitiés
sur ce terrain quand je viens ici je
connais personne mais maintenant ça va
mieux tout le monde je connais Ali et
ses coéquipiers ont créé leur propre
association au sein du club de baseball
et softball les slitters d'Épinal un
exemple d'inclusion par le sport qui
s'inscrit dans la semaine nationale de
l'intégration des étrangers et primo
arrivants on va les accompagner surtout
à structurer la section pour la
logistique pour les aider à acquérir du
matériel pour avoir les infrastructures
nécessaires à au développement du club
la politique ministérielle du ministère
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques c'est vraiment de faire la
politique de l'activité physique et du
sport pour tous donc évidemment que
quand on a réfugiés qui sont dans nos
territoires on se doit de pouvoir
faciliter la dernière intégration la
première équipe de cricket du Grand Est
a déjà de l'ambition cette discipline
importée du Royaume-Uni et le sport
national dans le pays d'origine des
joueurs French light football
le cricket au Bangladesh c'est un peu
comme le foot ici en France quand
j'étais petit je jouais au cricket tout
le temps après l'école mais quand je
suis venu en France personne n'y jouer
en équipe de France ça prendra du temps
mais je veux me concentrer sur le
cricket et uniquement sur le cricket
prochaine étape trouver un terrain
adapté aux trois disciplines le baseball
le softball est désormais donc le
cricket
du sport encore avec ces images
magnifiques venues de Corse l'île de
Beauté accueillait il y a quelques jours
la première édition du Raid Interfilière
universitaire les étudiants des
différentes sections de l'Université de
l'île de beauté se sont affrontés dans
plusieurs épreuves dont du kayak et de
la course à pied comme vous le voyez sur
ces images de nos confrères devia
télépaser la chaîne TNT de Corse
l'occasion de profiter de ces superbes
paysages et de féliciter ces courageux
participants
de splendide paysage et plage elle en a
beaucoup peu elle aussi la Martinique
est un lieu idéal pour le bon
développement de nombreuses espèces
parmi elles les tortues marines sont en
ce moment particulièrement surveillés la
période de ponte se poursuit sur
plusieurs littoraux pour protéger les
lieux d'éclosion des associations aux
formes des bénévoles à leur préservation
José le Chertier a suivi une sortie
organisée sur une plage de Lille pour la
rédaction de via ATV regardez
ces tortillon n'ont pas eu la chance de
rejoindre la grande bleue cette déni
prédaté donc en fait on sait pas on a
aucune trace donc on peut pas dire ce
que ce que ça peut être mais on voit
nettement que les tortues elles ont été
le nid a été creusés par un animal donc
on joue un être humain on sait pas moi
généralement c'est plus l'animal quand
il y a des coquilles comme ça qui
traînent au bois les tortues sont
relativement sensibles à l'environnement
et une place sale peut vite les
dissuader les bénévoles armés de leur
filet en profitent pour ramasser les
détritus c'est ce genre de choses
justement qui peut gêner les tortues
pour la pente des tortues une tortue qui
monte qui tombe sur un tas de de gravats
de ça en fait elle prendra pas donc elle
va repartir le périple continue
l'objectif du jour repérer les traces de
sortie de nid de l'océan à la Savoie de
ce côté de l'île deux espèces de tortues
viennent pondre la tortue verte et la
tortue imbriquée est parfois la tortue
lutte sur le parcours il n'est pas rare
de croiser des campeurs qui parlent le
comportement peut venir à la survie des
tortues on fait beaucoup de prévention
donc je donnais un petit dépliant pour
expliquer qu'on est dans des zones
préservées et que bah déjà pareil le feu
à même le sol interdit et pour
superviser ce groupe de bénévoles l' ONF
est alors côté
les tortues marines à savoir la
prédation de mangouste à savoir les
l'érosion de la plage la présence de
bivouac la présence de sagas quelques
bons gestes à retenir lors de l'éclosion
il était pourtant de rester à distance
vous pouvez éloigner tout ce qui
pourrait gêner le passage des
nouveaux-nés ainsi que les prédateurs ne
pas aller toucher ne surtout pas faire
trop de bruit pendant la pente et ne pas
utiliser le flash de votre appareil en
cas de problème un numéro d'urgence 06
96 234 235
stimuler les sens pour favoriser la
relaxation dans une ambiance obscure
c'est le principe du concept snow Zellen
apporté de l’étranger celui-ci se fait
peu à peu une place en France une
piscine dédiée à sa pratique vient
d'être aménagée à Metz diffusion de
lumière tamisée musique douce permettent
d'apaiser les usagers la pratique et
notamment employée pour aider les
enfants en situation de handicap
reportage de Lucie Philippot pour
Moselle TV regardez
accompagné de son papa Maddy 18 mois
atteinte d'une maladie génétique qui
entraîne un retard psychomoteur apprécie
profitez de l'eau sous le regard de sa
maman admirative ça permet de travailler
son équilibre
l'endurance aussi vous voyez sur les
tapis enfin plein d'exercices qu'elle
ferait pas en fait en salle avec ses
jouets habituels donc elle adore on a de
la chance le bassin est chauffé chose
dans une piscine municipale c'est pas
possible elle tombe très vite malade et
ça peut vite finir aux urgences en effet
la piscine est à 32 degrés la
température du bassin est une des
caractéristiques de la méthode
snowzolène cette pratique développée par
des Hollandais en 1970 fait appel aux
cinq sens grâce à un aménagement
particulier on a travaillé sur le lieu
par rapport à une ambiance qu'on a créé
grâce à la lumière la lumière n'étant
possible que si on peut fermer les
fenêtres fermer les rideaux comme on dit
on a travaillé aussi avec du son et ils
ont des petits objets pour travailler le
tactile qui sont au lisse ou rugueux ou
avec des petites bosses l'objectif de
cette séance et d'amener les enfants à
un bien-être et une familiarisation de
l'eau elle consiste à trouver un juste
équilibre entre stimulation et
relaxation ça peut être voilà de la
découverte d'exploration sensorielle
dans l'eau l'exploration motrice et puis
on accompagne les enfants à être bien
dans l'eau d'être en position verticale
d'accéder un peu la position ventrale ou
dorsale cette activité à la piscine Bon
Pasteur de Metz est exclusivement
réservée aux enfants présentant des
difficultés et aux personnes de
troisième âge
voilà restons à l'eau dans cette édition
pour découvrir tout à fait autre chose
l'exploitation d'un bateau historique
l'espérance 3 mise à l'eau l'an dernier
sur le lac d'Annecy cette reproduction
d'une barque à voile commerciale fait le
bonheur dorénavant des locaux et des
touristes scolaires entreprises ou
encore association profite ainsi d'un
voyage unique sur l'eau et dans un cadre
spectaculaire Victoria Lopez journaliste
pour la chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc a eu la
chance d'embarquer sur ce pendu
patrimoine regardez
et loge du silence patrimoine vogand
hommage au vent changeants sur le lac
d'Annecy l'espérance 3 et ses deux
grandes voiles épouse le paysage s'il y
a un siècle la barque servait à
distribuer de la marchandise entre les
deux rives sa reconstitution a
aujourd'hui une portée patrimoniale
pédagogique et environnemental nous
avons trois types de clientèle à savoir
principalement du grand public mais
aussi et surtout des scolaires depuis
début septembre beaucoup de scolaires on
a eu les écoles de juin le lycée des
bressis école également de verriers de
Sévrier des scolaires du grand public et
des entreprises mais il faut bien
prendre conscience que cette barque
cette brique est une brique patrimoniale
un emblème et un fleuron du lac d'Annecy
désormais puisqu'elle existe sur le lac
d'Annecy
la barque fait 20 mètres de long et de
haut 9 de large et 30 tonnes si elle
avance principalement grâce au vent elle
est équipée d'un moteur électrique d'une
puissance de 110 kW
en silence l'espérance mène donc aussi
une mission de sensibilisation
ambassadrice de la lenteur elle
accueille à son bord des chercheurs et
des acteurs de la préservation de
l'environnement cette barque latine elle
est là à la fois c'est un outil de
recherche c'est un outil pédagogique on
donne énormément d'informations sur sur
le lac d'Annecy sur les milieux naturels
on va présenter les réserves naturelles
à la fois de sur la partie terrestre et
aussi sur la partie lacus qui est
complètement inédit ce qui n'était pas
fait donc on peut permettre au grand
public de découvrir ses réserves via ce
magnifique outil qui est espérance 3
l'espérance 3 est la deuxième barque à
voile latine de France à naviguer à
nouveau après celle du Léman elle nous
replonge ainsi dans l'histoire des
hommes et des lacs et nous promet de
voguer encore longtemps au gris du vent
vous l'avez vu dans les titres il est
l'un des journalistes les plus connus et
les plus aimés des Français Philippe
Bouvard et l'auteur d'un nouvel ouvrage
retraçant sa vie professionnelle le
petit monde de don bouvardo c'est son
nom à cette occasion l'ancien rédacteur
en chef du Figaro est présentateur
historique des grosses têtes sur RTL m'a
accordé un entretien exceptionnel depuis
son domicile à Cannes sur la Côte d'Azur
Philippe Bouvard y évoque notamment sa
relation avec les hommes et les femmes
politiques français écoutaient à ce
propos cet extrait sur la gauche et
l'ancien président socialiste François
Mitterrand
j'ai mis un moment apprécié François
Mitterrand je l'ai même
vilipendée dans la boue pendant son son
premier septa mais au bout de 7 ans
j'étais obligé de reconnaître et dans
les colonnes de ma chronique du Figaro
mais résine qui n'était pas le support
le plus indiqué que ça avait été un très
bon Président bon à la suite de quoi
j'ai fait sa connaissance et on s'est
découvert une passion commune pour Jules
Renard bon et ensuite
j'avais applaudis de Gaulle qui était
mine de rien un homme de gauche
alors j'ai pas beaucoup aimé François
Hollande parce que c'est vrai qu'il
était plein de diplômes je crois que
c'est le plus diplômé tous les
présidents mais c'est pas celui qui
laisser le plus grand souvenir la preuve
c'est qu'il est scellé ses supplanter
par un jeune homme qu'il avait découvert
voilà la totalité de l'entretien que
Philippe Bouvard m'a accordé sera à
découvrir en exclusivité sur TV5 Monde
dans l'émission monte-carl Riviera il
faisait les samedis 12 et 19 novembre
prochain voilà tout à fait autre chose
et si vous intégriez comme Harry Potter
et ses amis l'école des sorciers de la
fiction à la réalité un pas vient d'être
franchi en Bretagne à l'occasion des
vacances de la Toussaint un château
fraîchement rénové propose de découvrir
l'univers de la sorcellerie entre grande
salle pour festoyer baguette magique et
spectacle tout est fait pour retrouver
le décor de la célèbre saga visite
guidée et enchantée avec un attacha
Astor pour la chaîne TVA à Rennes
c'est l'histoire d'un château datant de
la fin Renaissance transformé en une
mystérieuse école des sorciers et bien
là je vous fais découvrir la grande
salle des banquets du rocher portail la
nouvelle école des sorciers donc c'est
le fruit de d'un an de travail et là
c'est notre plaisir de voir voilà les
travaux finalisés pas de Poudlard ni de
Harry Potter
les propriétaires se sont inspirés de
l'histoire des lieux ah vous voyez donc
les bannières les quatre maisons qui
sont liées au personnage historiques
donc la maison Fauve d'or qui est donc
un lion qui était le constructeur du
château Renaissance la maison Buzard qui
est donc une buse la maison de
bouteflich et le cerf de lune qui voilà
a plus le symbole de ma famille la salle
des banquets accueillera chaque soir
plus de 200 qu'on vive pour un spectacle
d'une heure et demie animée par des
comédiens professionnels
pour rentrer dans l'école du rocher
portail passage obligatoire sous l'arche
de la vérité qui révèle votre maison
Maurice de la maison et pour la
répétition générale de grand fans de la
saga étaient déjà au rendez-vous j'ai
l'impression d'être au tout premier film
quand Harry rentre dans le dans la
maison en fait dans la dans la grande
salle pour le premier repas pendant le
repas servi aux nouveaux écoliers les
professeurs opèrent quelques tours de
magie sur une musique composée
spécialement pour l'événement
à chaque école de sorcier son atelier de
fabrication de baguettes magiques mais
aussi ses hiboux un petit peu peur
Charlotte se tient très bien et là c'est
notre petit bébé qui est en Gaudi
la soirée enchantée se termine par une
visite du château une manière d'attirer
les nouvelles générations dans les
monuments historiques c'est vraiment un
pari réussi l'histoire elle est bien
rodée les personnages sont vraiment
super les professeurs c'est parfait il
aura fallu un an de travail dont deux
mois pour la mise en scène du château et
côté écriture c'est madely Roussel qui a
inventé le scénario de la soirée pour
moi c'est juste magique que mes
personnages prennent vie ce soir avec
les comédiens c'est c'est vraiment j'en
ai la chair de poule c'est génial du 22
octobre au 5 novembre le rocher portail
attend 8000 visiteurs les après-midis et
3000 pour les banquets du soir
voilà et d'un tour de magie intéressant
nous désormais au travail d'une
association en faveur de la sauvegarde
du patrimoine fruitier de notre pays
arborée pomme c'est son nom dispose de
25 vergers conservatoires où sont
cultivés et préservés des centaines de
variétés de pommes certaines oubliées
représentent un patrimoine précieux pour
l'environnement précision avec ce
reportage de Valérie Leroux colléno pour
TBO la chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme en
Bretagne
voilà encore une récolte qui savait
riche en jus de crâne pour Jean-Pierre
chaque année en ce début d'automne les
membres de l'association arborés pomme
réalistes un grand travail d'inventaire
ces pommes leur ont été donnés par des
particuliers quand elles n'ont pas de
nom semble rare une petite enquête
auprès des gens qui nous l'ont amené
avant d'ailleurs s'il connaissaient la
personne qui l'a greffé on travaille par
rapport au livre anciens aussi parfois
on fait des empreintes génétiques qui
sont faites à Angers par l'INRA et c'est
ainsi que chaque année il découvre une
dizaine de nouvelles variétés anciennes
comme celle-ci la paume de l'estre
découverte à Douarnenez qu'on retrouve
très très rarement de temps en temps
dans les jardins de cure d'après Louis
XIV c'est l'importance de sauvegarder un
patrimoine génétique qui devrait pour un
avenir moins fade qui anime
l'association maintenant on crée entre 3
400 500 variétés de pommes par an dans
le monde leurs parents ne sont que une
dizaine de variétés vous n'achetez que
des cuisines la diversité génétique et
pratiquement nulle loin d'être des
musées ces vergers veulent être des
laboratoires à l'heure du réchauffement
climatique auxquels sont déjà confrontés
les producteurs de fruits on l'a très
bien vu en 2021 ce qu'on a eu un jeu
tardif en fait et du coup qui a vraiment
réduit la fructification les vergers
conservateurs on a repéré des variétés
anciennes qui vont être presque pas
touchés on va dire et qui peuvent être
aussi moins vulnérables à certains
parasites on va pouvoir utiliser
beaucoup moins de pesticides parce que
la pomme est quand même un fruit très
très traité en France l'association
Sauvegarde actuellement un si près de
750 variétés anciennes de fruits et
lancent aujourd'hui un appel au breton
car après la pomme elle souhaite se
fendre de recherche plus fructueuse sur
la poire allez on termine ce journal
avec un rendez-vous culturel à ne pas
rater si vous êtes du côté de Limoges le
musée des Beaux-Arts de la Ville expose
jusqu'en février prochain certaines des
plus belles œuvres de l'atelier de
Francis chigo le coloriste est notamment
l'auteur vous le voyez sur ces images de
7 à Limoges de vitraux qui ont orné près
de 500 édifices dans le monde des
monuments à la religieux en passant par
des créations pour des particuliers
c'est un véritable monde de lumière qui
s'ouvre devant les yeux des visiteurs
écouter à ce sujet le témoignage de la
petite fille du maître verrier au micro
d'Alain de
il a une maîtrise de la lumière à
travers la couleur donc on relie les
deux et c'est vrai que quelque soit le
style
quel que soit le cartonnier on retrouve
dans les vitrocigo cette alliance de la
lumière à travers sévère quand il
choisit un verre rouge il sait où il va
le mettre et quand il choisit un verre
bleu pâle il sait aussi où il va le
mettre
l'exposition consacrée au travail de
Francis chigo est donc avoir au Musée
des Beaux-Arts de Limoges jusqu'au 12
février prochain c'est la fin de cette
édition du Grand JT des territoires
merci de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]